une communauté une fois de plus déploré
sur les 13 victimes 11 et
afro-américaine 10 sont mortes
une fusillade diffusée en direct sur les
réseaux sociaux par ce tireur du 18 ans
qui aurait hurlé des injures racistes en
tirant sur les gens décevait
2009 john
dalli et ce crime dit elle a été commis
par un individu malade est dément
nourrie par la haine une haine publié
dans un document de 180 pages mis en
ligne par le suspect ils se
qualifieraient de suprémacistes blancs
et d'antisémite les enquêteurs analysent
le manifeste où il expliquera en détail
son plan pour cibler des quartiers noirs
les choses pierre libre c'est le mal
absolu dit le shérif motivés par la
haine raciale
venant d'une personne qui n'est même pas
d'une autre communauté
l'enquète judiciaire porte maintenant
sur le crime haineux motivés par des
groupes de suprématie blanche et
d'extrémisme violent
il faut qu'on travaille ensemble pour
combattre cette haine dit le président
qui demeure une tâche sur l'âme de
l'amérique une haine répandues sur les
réseaux sociaux mais aussi diffusée sur
les grands réseaux de télévision comme
la chaîne fox news 17 analystes
les américains blancs se font dire
quotidiennement qu'il faut qu'ils
résistent à la crise démographique dit
il sinon c'est la théorie du grand
remplacement
mer il faut condamner les personnalités
médiatiques et les politiciens qui
diffuse cette haine
avec cette tuerie la question du
contrôle des armes aux états unis refait
surface ainsi que l'accès aux chargeurs
de grande capacité
en attendant la communauté de beauf
l'eau se relève de cette fusillade
insensé qui rappelle celle de charlton
en caroline du sud en 2015 où neuf
personnes afro américaines avaient été
tués dans leurs églises par un jeune
extrémiste blanc la vice-présidente
kamala harris a affirmé qu'une attaque
sur une communauté est une attaque sur
toute la nation et le fbi a de nouveau
indiqué que le terrorisme intérieur
était la principale menace aux états
unis il ya des bootleggers guise
radio-canada washington